usa el método de eliminación para
obtener x y james y tengo dos ecuaciones
x + 2 6 y 4 x menos dos igual a 14 y
bueno vamos a recordar que esencialmente
el método de eliminación o de suma y
resta lo que nos dice es que tenemos que
sumar estas dos ecuaciones tanto el lado
izquierdo de estas dos ecuaciones como
el lado derecho de estas dos ecuaciones
y si te das cuenta tienen todo el
sentido lógico del mundo porque aquí
tengo un master gym y aquí tengo menos 2
james de tal manera que cuando yo el
asume me queda una ecuación con
solamente una incógnita pues lo que
quiero que te des cuenta es que cuando
yo sume más 2 james ya esto le sume
menos 2 james estas dos se van a
cancelar me va a dar de resultado 0 pero
date cuenta que esto tiene todo el
sentido lógico del mundo y es muy
importante que lo entiendas si nosotros
partimos de alguna de las dos ecuaciones
supongamos la de arriba x + 2 y igual a
6 tu has aprendido varias veces y en
varios vídeos y en varias clases que si
tú sumas o restas una constante de ambos
lados de la ecuación la igualdad se
mantiene porque estás haciendo la misma
operación de ambos lados de la igualdad
por lo tanto sumar
y una constante si se hace de los dos
lados la igualdad esto quiere decir que
la igualdad se va a conservar así que si
aplico esto mismo a esta igualdad y le
sumó 14 de ambos lados de la igualdad
entonces lo que va a pasar es que esta
igualdad se conserva pero ojo lo que me
dice la segunda ecuación es que 4 x
menos 2 james esto es exactamente igual
que 14 entonces en lugar de 14 voy a
poner 4 x menos 2 gen de la suma del
lado izquierdo de esta igualdad porque
aquí hay algo muy importante lo que me
están diciendo es que 4 x menos 2 y esto
es exactamente igual a 14 este es el
segundo dato que nos dan y como esto es
igual a 14 realmente cuando yo sumo
estas dos ecuaciones lo que estoy
haciendo es sumando 14 de ambos lados de
la ecuación y es justo en esto en donde
me baso que mi igualdad se conserva y
por lo tanto si puedo aplicar este
método de suma y resta pero bueno ya que
sabemos que si funciona este método pues
vamos a aplicarlo y que me queda x + 4 x
eso es lo mismo que 5x + 2 james menos 2
james pues estos dos se cancelan se van
o se hacen 0 mientras que del lado
derecho me queda 6 más 14 lo cual es 20
es decir que 5x es igual a 20
a ambos lados de la ecuación entre 5 voy
a poder obtener el valor de x es decir
estos dos se van y x es igual a 20 35 en
los cuales 4 perfecto y bueno ahora que
ya tenemos el valor de x lo que hay que
hacer es sustituir el valor de x en una
de estas dos ecuaciones para obtener el
valor de james así que voy a usar la
ecuación de arriba y dice x + 2 james
igual a 6 pero x vale 4 entonces me
queda 4 mayoría igual a 6 y si restó 4
de los lados de la ecuación estos dos se
van y me queda que 2 y es igual a 2 y
ahora he dividido entre 2 ambos lados de
la ecuación voy a obtener que es igual a
1 y perfecto ahora si ya tengo la
solución de este sistema de ecuaciones x
igual a 4 igual a 1 es la solución del
sistema de ecuaciones o el punto 4.1 es
la intersección de estas dos rectas y
bueno ahora que tengo ya la solución
sería muy bueno comprobar que realmente
esta sea la solución y para esto lo que
voy a hacer es sustituir el valor de x y
el de gemma en ambas ecuaciones para ver
si se cumple la igualdad en la primera
ecuación me queda que cuatro más dos por
uno es decir x + 2 james esto tiene que
ser igual a 6 lo cual es cierto perfecto
ya tengo una menos
y en la otra tengo que 4 x x es decir 4
x 4 menos dos por james es decir menos
dos por uno porque llévale uno esto
tiene que ser igual a 14 y me queda 16
menos 2 esto es igual a 14 perfecto
también se cumple la segunda igualdad
por lo tanto la solución de este sistema
de ecuaciones es x igual a 4 y igual a 1